when I last talked about the show I had
only seen three episodes and things were
iffy they did not improve so guys I
really debated whether or not I was
gonna come back and address the issue of
hiring fists because I have now finished
it if you're wondering why I'm as
scruffy as I am and probably not
sounding at my best I've been sick the
last few days and part of how I have
been spending that my time was by
getting through the remainder of iron
fist
I had posed the question twice up to
this point does it suck well first
positing the question what happens if it
sucks and then last time I'm talking
about only the first three episodes does
it suck and having now seen the entire
scope of the thing yeah guys it kind of
does and I know I'm not the only person
say obviously the critics ripped into
this thing like you wouldn't believe so
you know part of me felt like I don't
have anything to add to the conversation
but then I realized that part of the
reason that I was slogging through it
was because I knew I was gonna have to
rant about it and I would have felt like
a jerk if I hadn't at least finished the
whole thing through so I was watching it
out of spite but look not everything is
bad in this so let's start positive the
big positive for me Madame Gao I loved
her before I loved getting more of her
she's still good she's still enigmatic
just this real sense of power in this
little woman even when she doesn't you
know surprise sends somebody across the
room I like her I like her a lot before
I like her even more now I will be happy
to see more of her I would like her to
come back in the defenders I mentioned
before that the corporate intrigue
intrigued me fittingly enough and that
kind of held truth of the whole thing I
think the storyline I had the most
investment and ultimately was in the
Meacham's there was something very it
was almost kind of Lannisters esque if
you follow the game of Thrones in terms
of this family really striving for power
and yet they don't always seem to be on
the same page and they don't always seem
to want the same things yet they're all
striving to to maintain control and I
liked that I would liked watching that
play out I liked seeing where different
characters landed at different points in
the story I thought
was really interesting with Harold sort
of how lied to me to get a sense of what
his deal was and even when I found out
oh yeah this is your warning spoilers
I'm talking about the whole thing so
even when we find out his deal where
every time he comes back from the dead
he's basically a little worse I still
found that interesting because there's a
part of him that's still striving to
make his family better but there's this
darkness inside him that is growing
because he is now dieting and come back
again so now he's worse than he was
before and that whole dynamic I found
interesting I thought the performances
for them were pretty solid although you
know it probably should be a little
telling that in your kung-fu action
series the story that interests me the
most has the least to do with that but
anyway moving on sneaking positive
Colleen wing there were issues with her
but the actress I'm sorry I don't know
her name and I'm I'm still recovering so
I don't feel up to looking up stuff
right now I'm just rambling but she had
good presence in GU charisma I'm not a
huge fan of the character use I may come
back to that
Claire Claire's always good I mean
everything rosario Dawson does she is
always good even if the overall thing is
crap now before I get into the flat-out
bad stuff I'm gonna straddle the line
briefly with one thing and that is
damning by fine praise which is that I'm
gonna sing about what action scene that
I really liked
but it's the only one I'm gonna talk
about in a positive light because all
the other action scenes I didn't enjoy
but that is the fight in China with I
for lack of a better term drunken master
that was fun and it was inventive I mean
not completely original like I said it
is drunk and master but that was but and
I liked that character as well I really
wish we got more of him me was fun and
he was funny and he was energetic and he
had a good sort of mocking rapport with
Danny so that was a good fight and we'll
transition into the junk because like I
said all the other fights that okay I'm
gonna I was debating whether I want to
open with my overriding criticism that
sinks the whole thing or whether I want
to build up to it I think I'm gonna try
and build up to it because once they
start rambling about that is gonna
dominate everything so first of all the
stakes I don't really
what they were because like what is
being threatened throughout this show
the control of the RAND Corporation okay
why do I care who runs this corporation
especially because they I don't really
understand what why Danny wants it and
what he would do with it if he had it
and how it would be any better than what
the Meacham's are doing because I mean
yeah there's some skeevy stuff guard but
in the world and if we're being at least
semi realistic they are not the world's
worst corporation like that drug that
Danny was like we're gonna sell it at
cost like that's fine in opal or
anything and everything but as even the
board laid it out it's like okay we are
going to make it available and it will
get sold to the people who need it we
will just also make a profit off it I'm
like I kind of find that acceptable in
the corporate world
so who controls ran don't care don't get
where the stakes are there's a threat to
Kunlun well that might have worked if we
knew anything about the place whatsoever
we don't really see it at all and so
it's really hard to be invested in the
fate of a place that we haven't seen we
don't know all we know is the little
bits that Danny has told us and it's not
really clear you know Wyatt say yeah I
mean we know the hand wands that we
don't really know why what they would do
with it what what is the value of konga
why should I be worried that it's
threatened I understand there's answers
to all this like in the comics but I'm
restricting this to the TV show because
the TV show has to stand on its own two
feet I mentioned the action scenes
already I guess the main thing is well
there's there's a lot okay I can't even
say what the main thing is there's a lot
that doesn't work about most of the
fight scenes first of all a lot of them
are slow and I mean the movements
especially when it's Danny and it's
obviously Finn Jones the actor Heath he
does not sell the physicality of someone
who is does combat martial arts very
well at all he can kind of sell the
slower tight GE kind of thing but like
there's no tension in his limbs and his
fingers you know when he when he does
something like this and he goes to hit
somebody you know this is me doing it
with tension of my fingers he does it a
bit more like this and I'm like that
makes the hitch looks offed because
regardless of what you tell me this is a
real way to do it or not it doesn't
matter because when this
hit somebody there's no sense of impact
or sense of tension when this hits
somebody there's a sense of tension and
impact if the hips don't look like they
hurt it doesn't sell the fight and every
time he was fighting nothing he did felt
like it hit felt like it hurt and then
it was the mess of things that they did
to cover up the fact that they obviously
knew he wasn't very good in the fights
like the high angle shots where they
could easily drop in the stunt double
how many cuts there were I mean these
sorts of fights are best when they are
allowed to have long taste I said way
before the first reviews even started
coming out what I was looking forward to
our long take kung fu fight and I mean
these these things are chopped up to
heck and what does this show have
against lighting a scene properly they
do it in the action scenes a lot and I
know part of that that's another way to
try and hide the fact that the action is
not very good but they didn't like
normal scenes horribly late you barely
see anything and that look at the hand
the whole the whole thing with the hand
was almost interesting but then they
opened a can of worms and then just let
them crawl all over the place cuz we get
this this notion this interesting notion
that maybe the hand isn't bad but
they're just they're after something
good but maybe just using harsh means to
get it this is sort of introduced and
there's potential in that idea but it
doesn't work for a couple of reasons
first of all as I said we haven't
properly established Kunlun and so if we
don't have proper expectations
established in this place that has been
training Danny you can't subvert those
expectations because again all we know
is stuff that we know only secondhand so
the idea of oh they're really the bad
guys maybes like that has minimal impact
besides me just going ok
I'm listening it also doesn't work
because they drop that angle so quickly
you say oh no this hand is bad too but
then there's the whole idea of like this
beat there's more than one hand that
feels like a cop-out because they
suddenly feels like somebody had the
idea look what if we introduced the idea
of the hand not being that bad and then
someone's like Madame Gao is obviously
very bad as I okay so so there's more
than one segment of the hand then except
that that doesn't
pan out at least not as they laid it out
here because okay so there's segments of
the hand is there an overriding force of
the hand that is like above these these
two sort of battling segments if so
which one are they more likely to align
with so like is Madame Gao version of
the hand is that true or is vicunas
version of the hand true or if neither
is the case and it's in the hand is in
fact not very well organized at all and
it's just a whole bunch of just assorted
segments all claiming to be the hand but
really none of them are because they
can't agree on anything I kind of would
like to know if that's the setup do
that's the only thing I can come up with
but that's just me
trying to fit these pieces together now
I mentioned briefly calling ultimately
doesn't work for me she doesn't work
mainly because of character use I think
the actress played it well enough but
you know the characters I mean the
obvious that they hooked up you know I
had a big sigh of relief when Danny said
oh I took a vow of chastity and right oh
good they're not gonna turn this into a
pointless love engine it's now a
pointless love interest and but vow
chastity never came up again like not
even an acknowledgement that he broke
this or what that means or doesn't mean
anything or what will he lose his Pat
with what and I suppose that will just
transition right into Danny and Danny is
the big thing that does not work so all
right I'm only gonna bring this up
because I did a video talking about it
before in terms of the racial casting I
did ultimately come to the conclusion
before the show it started airing that
maybe it would have been better if they
cast a chinese-american actor in the
park having now seen the show it would
have made absolutely no difference
whatsoever it wouldn't have helped to
show either way and it wouldn't have
heard it anymore because I had heard
people in response to what I wrote sort
of make the argument of sort of some of
them hesitate to call them benefits but
some of the story aspects that in the
comics have been milked out of the fact
that Danny is why mostly having to do
was training in Kunlun and how he is
adopted into the society but as an
outsider within it and that's hinted at
very minuscule E in the show but it's
not properly my friend a drama a gang
because we don't really see Conlon so I
feel like changing his ethnicity really
wouldn't have impacted the story and
what are the same
fact if he just had bitten you know
hadn't been living in America he would
have been just as much of an outsider
regardless of ethnicity but making him
chinese-american would not have fixed
anything there's so much more and this
way I'm glad they didn't because there's
so much wrong with this show I would
really hate to think that if they had
cast a Chinese American actor that there
would have been a certain stripe of fan
who would have come in and said see this
is what happens when you change the race
of a character when the problems with
this show have nothing to do with that
and even if they had done that wouldn't
have been that would've been the problem
either so at this point I'm glad they
didn't given how much the thing sucks
and I'm glad people don't have that to
scapegoat Danny between being rich and
how pompous he is in terms of his
training like I am the office yeah you
know what he you know what he feels like
the hipster with prayer beads wishing
namaste to the barista at Starbucks
she's giving him his chai tea and then
he doesn't leave a tip that's who he
feels like he walks into call his dojo
and starts lecturing her on how to teach
and how to run a dojo he spells Buddhist
aphorisms out of nowhere his own person
like these what Danny is about like is
he 9 Eve is he too trusting is what he
is the most easily manipulated lead
character I can ever ever ever
everybody manipulates him Harold Meechum
manipulates him Madame Gao manipulates
him Colin wing manipulates him but Kuno
manipulates him Davos manipulates him
every single person in the show
manipulates him like that it's stupid
easy and I've already seen people like
making arguments like well you know he
was away for 15 years what do you expect
it doesn't matter if you can justify it
it makes him impossible to root for as a
lead character because he doesn't show
any sort of understanding or Drive he's
not learning at any point and even if
you could justify that behavior that
doesn't make
a good lead it just gives you a
justification for this lousy thing I'm
having to watch and it doesn't help that
for the vast majority show I don't
understand what Danny wants I don't know
why he's interested in Rand as a company
by the end I'm still not entirely sure
is it just about the names and about his
father's like his he doesn't see you
think my crap about the money you know
why did he come back you know like he
didn't seem to I didn't come back to
fight the handler eventually the why did
he come back does get answered very sort
of haphazardly toss-up but it's like
episode 11 and up until that point I'm
like I don't understand why he's here I
don't understand why he's doing anything
that he's doing how am I supposed to
root for somebody who I don't get and I
can't relate to and I do not understand
how he ever became the iron fist beyond
just on so many levels mainly the big
one is just the total lack of discipline
the total lack of control and I get that
the final test is just defeating the
dragon I'll come back King Dragun so I
understand that it's just that and all
he has to do is survive and he becomes
the iron fist but how was he ever
disciplined or you know whatever enough
that they would pick him and allow him
to take that trial I don't buy it
he doesn't he talks about oh push my
emotions that he never has control of
his emotions not even at the beginning
so it's not like we're watching him
crack over time he never seems to be in
proper control of his emotions exactly
how was the iron fist tie into his
emotions that is completely inconsistent
all over the place too sometimes it
seems activated by his anger later on is
completely thrown off to these two angry
and he can't concentrate
they keep tossing out the concept of Chi
they don't really explain it
even within world and it's like being
treated like it's the force this
all-purpose plot installation oh gee
look I realized how much I hated Danny
when I realized the points of watching
the show which I was most likely to go
yeah where all the points when other
characters told him he was an idiot when
word Meechum did it I cheered when
Claire did it I cheered when other
people point out how stupid he is I'm
like yes cuz he's so dumb and even aside
the fact
he doesn't sell the choreography he's
not even in the context of the story
he's not the best warrior so why would I
root for this guy he's not a great
fighter he's not a great leader I don't
understand his motivations I can't even
really bounce over the fact that he's a
good guy he's got some vague moral
things like okay fine he's not strong
well he doesn't seem worthy of the power
that he has he doesn't seem to
appreciate the fact that maybe he's
don't earn being worthy of that he's
just got this very up I want it so I am
the I he doesn't even understand what
he's doing
oh my god how stupid was that thing is
like some in the iron fist hmm now open
your hand hmm oh look I understand he
was showing him something new but just
the way you trans like that's like open
your hand oh my god my head does not
need to be a fist this is amazing and
you know they really they really should
have just tossed the idea of doing iron
fist cuz I'm pretty sure it was
something that they landed that by
default because when they decide that
we're gonna use the Jessica Jones like
okay well we'll do Jessica Jones and
then your Luke Cage very obvious thing
to spin off from that cuz we catch part
of her story
cool well you know we do Luke Cage we
should really do iron fist because
they're so often paired together and
then they lock themselves down and
committed to that I feel like they never
had a plan for this they never knew what
they were gonna do and they should have
candid the incident that they realized
they weren't going to give this thing a
budget to properly realize come on as a
location or the goddamn dragon to Chloe
you build up a dragon he fought a dragon
and all we get to glowing eyes in the
dark you don't promise what you can't
deliver I just hope to god that this guy
has amazing chemistry with Luke Cage
when we get to the defenders cuz if he
doesn't there is no reason to keep this
guy around he's insufferable and he is
going to be the brick around the neck of
this has that franchise because pretty
much everything else I talked about can
be improved we can do better fight
choreography we can do longer takes we
can get a freaking lighting set
been there we can come up with a plot
that makes more sense but unless they
recast we're still stuck with this guy
in this interpretation of the character
and it's awful so that's it guys you
know what I think has been really
telling about this when I first started
watching it on Netflix because you know
they've got the star rating when I first
started watching it I think it was even
the day that it premiered or it was soon
after the then was had five stars
because obviously that's based off user
ratings by the time I finished it it had
dropped down to like maybe three and a
third I think it's very clear that you
know hardcore people went in there and
they gave it the five star either on
hope or maybe because they genuinely
liked it if you liked it fine that's
great but I think as more and more
people are getting through it it's
becoming clearer and clearer that not
everyone is loving this thing so what
I'd like to say is as much as I just had
to rant all this out did did you
actually like iron fist if you did I
want to hear about it I want to hear I
want to have a reasonable discussion as
to what it was you actually liked about
it so if you wanted that or heck if you
want to pile onto the hate I just laid
on to this thing whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
counselling geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]